- Welcome everyone, those here at Yale
participating in person
and the many more that are
participating via zoom.
My name is Claudia Valeggia,
I am a professor of Anthropology
here at Yale and the Chair of the council
on Latin American Liberian studies.
And it is a great pleasure
to introducing you to our guest today.
So, I am delighted to welcome you,
and our distinguished guest,
to the first event of the Latin American
Policy leader series.
The series, and this is a mouthful,
the series is generously supported
by The George Herbert
Walker Junior Lecture Fund
in International Studies
at the MacMillan Center
for International Area Studies.
I said it all in one.
(class laughs)
First, a brief thanks, should be longer,
but a brief thanks to
the many people involved
in organizing today's
event, our team at CLAIS,
particularly Agustina and Asia
and Josh for being wonderful,
a wonderful team supporting this event.
Then the Fox International
Fellowship Program,
the program on peace and development
at the Yale MacMillan Center
and the Office of International
Affairs, thank you all.
Before I introduce our
speaker and moderator today,
I want to share a few words
about our Latin American
Policy Leader Series.
Latin America is a home
to some of the world's
largest democracies and the
region has made enormous strides
in consolidating democratic
norms and human rights
since the end of the cold war.
The Latin American Policy Leader Series
seeks to create dialogue about the future
of democratization, human
rights and development
with policy leaders
from across the region.
Our hope is to engage these leaders
in vigorous and respectful
discussion about pressing issues.
As part of the series, we
are pleased to be welcoming
the former Environmental
Ministry of Ecuador
and President of the World
Wildlife Fund International,
Yolanda Kakabadse on March
11th, so mark your calendars.
On April 19th, we will host a
discussion with the President
of the Inter-American
Court of Human Rights,
Ricardo Pérez Manrique.
And on May 20th, we
will wrap up the series
with Maria-Noel Vaeza, Regional Director
of Latin American and the
Caribbean for the UN Women.
Now, regarding today's
event and our speaker,
I am delighted to introduce
the Secretary General
of the organization of American
states, Dr. Luis Almagro,
who is originally from Uruguay
and is a lawyer by profession.
He's currently serving his second term
as Secretary General of the
Organization of American states.
The Secretary General was
Uruguay's Foreign Minister
between 2010 and 2015,
during his tenure Uruguay
welcomed former prisoner from Guantanamo,
granted asylum to dozens
of Syrian families,
who were victims of civil war,
and secure endorsement of
the group of Latin American
Caribbean countries ruler,
for its election to a seat
on the United Nations Security
Council in January, 2016.
He was also ambassador
to China for three years
after occupying senior diplomatic posts
in his country's foreign ministry,
and its embassies in Germany and Iran.
In addition, he was elected as a Senator
in Uruguay's national
elections in October 2014.
Luis Almagro was first
elected as Secretary General
of the OAS in March 18th, 2015,
with a support of 33
of the 34 member states
and one abstention.
He was reelected for a
second term on May 20, 2020.
After the Secretary's general remarks,
our class faculty member
professor Ana De La O,
we'll sit up in our living room here
for discussion before
opening up for questions
and answer sessions
with those in this room,
and also attendees that
are joining us virtually.
Ana De La O is a professor
in the Department
of Political Science here at Yale,
and is also the Director
of Undergraduate Studies
for Latin American studies,
which is our signature major,
and those of you who are
considering majors as students,
please contact Ana or
CLAIS for more information.
She's also affiliated with the Institute
of Social and Policy studies
and the Jackson School of Global Affairs.
Her research plays to
the political economy
of poverty alleviation, clientalism,
and the provisions of public words.
Professor De La O is the
author of numerous articles
in journals, such as the American journal
of Political Science and
the Journal of Politics,
as well as the book, "Crafting Policies
"to End Poverty in Latin America."
A must read.
She teaches courses on
the political economy
of poverty alleviation,
paradigms of political economy,
the politics of redistribution
and quantitative research methods.
Thank you so much, Ana,
for lending your expertise
and moderating our conversation today.
I understand the Secretary General
will make some brief
remarks, so please listen in
and be ready with any questions
for the Q and A session.
And I want to add a
personal anecdote here,
I am here, presiding this event
in part thanks to the OAS.
I came to the United States to do my PhD
with funding from the OAS,
alone, that will be justly paid
(crowd laughter) on monthly
installments that allowed us
to pursue our degree without
having to work outside.
So thank you to the OAS.
So without further ado, please
please join me in welcoming
Secretary General of OAS, Luis Almagro.
(crowd claps)
- Thank you very much to all of you.
It's a great pleasure to be here.
The first thing in
democracy, in Latin America
and the Caribbean progress
and peace development.
If we see the hemisphere, of course,
we may see some serious challenges
related to the state of
democracy in some countries.
The conditions for progress
and development, always uncertain,
and the conditions of these are
related to security matters.
And of course,
the challenges that we
have in the hemisphere.
So all this means that we have,
I will have to enlist some
failures related to all this.
As you may imagine, democracy
is not always so healthy.
Security is not always available
for all Latin Americans, Caribbean people.
Development is always
uncertain and then we fear,
we need to do something
else in order to jump out
of the trap of underdevelopment
that we always are.
Of course, for me, there
is an obvious conclusion
looking at the hemisphere,
the better the democracy,
the better the conditions for development,
the better are the
conditions for security,
better conditions for
access to rights and equity.
Democracy, it means
best possible citizens,
best possible institutions
are as strong as possible,
efficient institutions that
can deliver to the people,
that can provide to the people,
that can find solutions
for the structural problems
of the people.
Of course, we have some
structural problems.
Some of them, they have been with us
for 200 years of independent life.
I think, of course we have
also new ones, old grievances,
new grievances, old goons, new ones.
We have a structural
problem, the past 200 years,
we are the most unequal
region in the world.
And this is not just means inequality
in the context of wealth distribution,
but also access to rights,
we are very unequal
how people access to
right in our hemisphere.
We still discriminate a lot,
we still have a lot of serious challenges.
In order to resolve the
conditions for everybody
to have a fair life and
opportunities in the hemisphere.
We are facing serious
problems related to this.
Inequality, it affects our democracies,
but it affects also our
levels of development.
A better democracy, and of course,
we need to have better
conditions of equality
in the hemisphere, better
access to right for people,
and to be able from there
to have better conditions
for development.
If we think that inequality
is just a political issue,
we are wrong, inequality is
an issue, cross cutting issue,
that affects practically every level
of the life that we
live in the hemisphere.
We have, of course, a
lot of challenges ahead,
we have to fix this.
We have not worked it hard
in the past 200 years,
we have a big problem about that.
I always mention the case of the rules
for the land reform of Artigas, 1815,
that refers that (speaks Spanish),
those unhappy, those most vulnerable
to be the most privileged
in the context of politics.
And he identified the
main vulnerable groups
in what it was the one that entailed them.
And they were with children,
they were Afro descendant population,
they were Indigenous people.
200 years later, we have the same pattern
of poverty in the country,
we have single mothers
count for a lot of the poverty
of the region of the country.
Afro descendant people, they
count for 8% of the population
and for 40% of the poverty
and Indigenous people,
they were terminated immediately
after the independence,
so they don't count anymore.
That means we really have some
serious structural problems
because that, that is considered
the most equal country
among Latino Americans,
is still the one that,
it still have the same,
very same structural
problems that it has had
for quite a while.
We are supposed to come
from very liberal ideas.
Our independence, our constitutions,
they were like, they have
a democratic vocation,
most of them, they took the Thomas Paine,
and they took the principles
of the American Revolution,
of the French Revolution.
But when we scratch it a
little bit, just a little bit,
we know that we are a highly
paternalistic, we are unequal,
we have patterns of racists
practically everywhere.
We have this poverty, structural
poverty in the hemisphere.
So, we still have a lot to do
to put this liberal
mind, this liberal ideas,
these advanced constitutions
and legislation into practice,
to bring solutions for the real people.
That it depends where they
were born and the class,
the neighborhood, and the
region in the country,
and of course, race and gender
and other levels of
inequality and discrimination
that exist in the region.
And of course, this all brings patterns
of exclusion and polarization.
And I am presuming the
problems in order that we,
those are the things
that we need to address.
We need to address this in order
to have better democracies,
we need to address this in order
to have a better
possibility for development.
Exclusion and polarization,
it comes with this,
with what I have just said
of the levels of inequality,
of this crosscut and
inequality in our countries.
We have in the past years,
we even moved to further
polarization in our countries.
Sometimes, we have seen in
the region two projects,
impossible to reconciliate
between each other,
passing to the second round of elections.
And maybe sometimes because citizens say,
"Look for radical approach
to for solutions."
Sometimes on the one
side or the other side,
sometimes because we are just
losing the common ground,
sometimes because we are
not able to handle properly
the political discussion,
the political participation
that come with social media,
we have all these challenges ahead.
It has been very hard for
us to develop a substantial
and constructive and positive agenda
based on our political discussions.
And we have been falling
apart in these discussions
becoming more and more paralyzed.
And not only paralyzations,
it goes sometimes
to the immunization of
the political adversity,
what is even more irrational,
and that brings another problem.
That is, you remain in
power no matter what.
And that remaining in
power is always the base
for some people, of course,
to get some immunity,
impunity, or amnesty,
and it has been proved
in this hemisphere that
no dictator is safe
from the long memory of
human rights justice,
or the long arm of human rights justice.
So that the only way
dictators remain impugned
is because they remain in power.
That is the only way for amnesty,
that is the only way for
immunity, for impunity.
The impunity that comes
from remaining in power,
whatever the cost may be.
And we have seen in that sense,
that we pass from one
dictatorship in the hemisphere
to three dictatorships
in some four, five years,
six, seven years, maybe some
process were more accelerated,
Some process were more
gradual, but it went that way.
Looking for these conditions
of impunity, of immunity.
And that of course are the challenges
of dealing also with zeros sum mentality,
that is taking a lot from us.
It's like, we are not able to find the way
that we can work together, but
how we can defeat the other
and how we can take
advantage of that victory.
We have to, we are looking for
relevance in the wrong way.
We need to look for relevance
based on the solutions
that we find for our people,
how we eliminate discrimination,
how we eliminate poverty,
how we eliminate inequality,
how we create better
conditions for the people
to integrate and to
consolidate a common ground
that may allow institutions
to work in the long term.
To execute plans in the long term,
to design plans in the long term.
All this, it means sometimes
going back to square one,
institutions going back to square one,
political system going back to square one,
or just holding to
power in no matter what,
no matter how bad is
your humanitarian crisis,
no matter how bad is immigration crisis,
no matter how bad is your corruption,
no matter how bad are your
human rights violations,
just remain in power.
And that school of thought,
regrettably is something
that we also have in this hemisphere,
also have among Latino Americans.
What we do, we deal
with political systems,
we try to bring stability and we try
to strengthen the democratic institutions.
We try to create conditions
for transparent government,
we try to create the conditions
for the better projects
that can bring and develop
according to the pillars
of the organization, democracy,
access to right security.
The thing is that this
is a serious challenge,
And we, you expect an organization
with not enough financial resources,
not enough human resources
to fix these four pillars
in a practically, a hundred
percent efficient way.
And in a context, of course,
that we have today of conflict,
of social and political
conflict escalation,
but the solution is this, the OAS,
it means materialists, and
that it means means stability.
That is what, how we work,
how we create conditions
that can bring better
democratic governments.
And that is how we push more or less,
most of the time we can
be an immortal force,
and that is the thing of the organization.
I mean, our projects cannot have the scale
of financial institutions, but
we are a strong moral force
in creating conditions that
can help some governments
and democratic governments,
and democratic institutions
to verbalize and to face
the threats that they have,
the threats that they
have that are related
to the existential threats
that we have in the hemisphere.
And I go to Caribbean and
Central American countries.
For example, first of one,
the one that is challenging
their own existence is climate change.
I mean, we have a group of
small islands that year by year,
are devastated by hurricanes,
two, three countries,
in like Caribbean countries,
Central American countries,
they deeply affected, but what is going on
in climate change in the world?
And for us, climate
change is not a rhetoric,
it's not a speech, it is something
that it brings a serious
impact to million of people,
thousands of people, every, every year.
We are the first frontier
of climate change.
Practically, no other
region has in the world,
has this impact, serious impact,
every year that we are facing.
The other existential threat is security.
We have a serious challenge there
and something that we
definitely need to address.
We are 8% of the world population,
we count for 78% of violent death.
Violent death, and we have 15 of the 20
most violent cities in the world.
We are the definitely
far to deliver solutions
from the crisis and the
terror that organized crime
and drug trafficking is bringing
to our countries in the hemisphere.
We have not been able to reverse that,
I think, we need stronger and
more efficient institutions
that definitely each
country can hardly have.
If you look at the budget of
drug trafficking organization,
compared to what may have,
you know, police station,
some where in our countries,
definitely they are far behind
and they have far stronger,
harder challenges than anybody.
We need international
cooperation for that.
We need a permanent engagement
of developed countries,
bringing better conditions
of security to our countries.
And of course, a better
regional cooperation
related to this matter.
And that at a certain moment
that we can depend ourself
because our police is
much more professional,
because our judges are far more efficient,
and because our prosecutors are better
when they investigate,
we have all these talents
in order to create
a security matrix for the continent.
The other existential
threat is corruption.
And the conditions of
lack of transparency,
definitely transparency are always there.
We have not been able to overcome,
maybe we are doing better
than in previous years,
but more of the political
system is scrutinized.
More of the political
system is investigated.
And there are more persecutions
related to corruption in public affairs.
Nevertheless, we are far
from what it should be.
And the fight of corruption
start to avoid in that,
every government in action
is affected by that.
It doesn't mean to indulge
the previous corruption,
but it doesn't mean to persecute
the previous administration
that it cannot, it can never work
as a way of fighting corruption.
Fighting corruption
should be a general thing,
starting by yourself, by what
you do and the challenges
that you have about your own moral
and your Republican property
that you can deliver.
And the fourth challenge is, of course,
the fourth existential
threat are dictatorships,
and we are having more
dictatorships, as I said,
and they really affect because they bring
all the bad practices to the hemisphere
and to the political
systems of the hemisphere.
Bad practices are very contagious,
are very difficult to control even,
to bring good practices
from one country to other,
you need a project, you need
financing, you need experts.
You need a lot of work and a program
to execute that project.
But practices, they have to spread
without nobody saying anything,
suddenly, you will see this
and this and this copying that,
and starting this way of doing things.
And that is why to have
dictatorships in the hemisphere
is it's bringing a lot
of bacterial infections
to our democracies.
And I wish that one day
we can have a hemisphere
free of dictatorships, free
of human rights violation,
free of crimes against humanity,
and that it will mean a step
forward in our development,
mainly because this
dictatorships that you see them,
they are mainly failed systems.
They have failed completely in
social and production terms,
and they are not, they have not been able.
And even one of them is one
of the richest countries
that exist in the world,
with a lot of oil,
a lot of mineral
resources, a lot of energy,
a lot of whatever you want in this world,
and now is a broken country,
how will you create that?
Because of a plan, a
formula that never worked.
It is a formula of the
ideology of dictatorship.
And this is not from, for
the right or for the left,
this is the formula of a dictatorship.
And that's why I started
saying in this hemisphere,
what we see is that better democracies
is better development conditions,
better security conditions,
better access to right.
We have a lot, a lot
ahead, and definitely,
we need to address some of these issues
because they are like
running out of control.
Human rights violations,
executives co-opt in the
judiciary, our weak parliaments
and all these, it needs to be built
if we want to be developed
countries at a certain moment,
if we want to have better conditions
for the living of
everybody in our societies.
So it's, sometimes people think
this is a gloomy approach.
And, I think, I say, I would never be able
to resolve my problems
if I don't face them,
if I don't identify them,
I don't know which are these problems.
That's why we have to start from here,
if we want to have what the title says,
it's translating democracy
for progress and peace.
That's it.
(crowd claps)
- Sure, yeah.
Hi everyone, as Claudia
mentioned, I'm Anna De La O,
and thank you so much,
thank you so much to CLAIS.
Wow, I don't even feel it anymore.
(group laughs)
Thank you so much to
CLAIS for the invitation
to moderate this panel, and of course,
it's an honor for me to be
here, Secretary General.
Thank you so much for those
very thought provoking remarks.
And you have already touched
on a few of the things
that I was planning to ask you about,
but I do want to start with the point
about strengthening democracy,
because as both Claudia
and you, Secretary General mentioned,
the region has made great strides
consolidating representative democracy,
but there are signs of
democratic backsliding
in some countries, of course,
and the democratic
breakdown in some cases.
And also according to
the last Latin American
Public Opinion Project,
only 60% of Latin Americans
would say that they prefer democracy
to any other system of government,
which is quite alarming.
And so I wonder, Secretary
General, whether we should,
we have been focusing too
much on the role of elections
and free and fair elections in the region,
And whether you think
that there is now room
to think about more direct forms
of democratic participation,
and also your remarks
make me think, when you
talked about polarization,
inequality, security problems,
whether you think the region
should be going in that direction or not
to more direct forms of participation.
- Yeah, first thing democracy
is, is a work for everybody.
I mean, we have to start
from the very beginning,
we have to be better citizens,
more tolerant citizens,
and more flexible and more
looking at the perspective
of what solutions we can
achieve and how we can build
better things for our society.
So I always hope that we can engage
in better informing people
and being closer to the people
in order to bring solutions in that,
that may help everybody
to be a better citizen.
Of course, this is not the only thing.
I mean, we need to have
a stronger institution.
So you were referring to
some service and polls
that, of course, there is not so much
of trust in democracy these days.
but this makes me remember a phrase
that my mother used to say,
that it was, (speaks Spanish).
"You never know that you are fine
"until you are not fine anymore."
And we have seen that
because those that they miss democracy,
in Cuba, Venezuela,
those are in Nicaragua.
They really want, they want democracy
back in their countries.
So those that they are not
so happy with democracy
these days, it's because, of course,
they are maybe more unhappy
about lack of efficiency
of their government, or maybe not so good
democratic governance itself.
So that is the biggest
issue, but we can build
a better democracy, also
building better institutions,
we need better institutions these days.
We need institutions that
can help us with solutions
and can help us in real time.
If you don't have institutions,
you stop helping people.
If some countries, they
have a structural problems
and the institutions are, have
been very weak for decades
or maybe more, and you have some countries
where the degradation of
institutions have been
more of a gradual thing until
they are completely useless.
And I don't like to mention it,
but the case of Venezuela
is an example of that.
Suddenly the Minister of Health
cannot deliver solutions
in the health system,
the Minister of Food, but cannot feed
all the people of the country.
The security, the Ministry of Interior
cannot help people related
to security matters
and not, they cannot even
protect the territory.
I mean, the armed forces
of Venezuela went to fight
the dissident of dissident
of FARC and Apure,
and they took as his
heart punishment, beaten.
So, not even they can control
the territory properly.
So that is when you
deteriorate institutions
to a level that you cannot help anybody,
and you cannot deliver
solutions for anybody.
So you need institutions
that can be efficient.
The messianic approach is
of course a different way.
I mean, the Messias, they don't
need a strong institutions,
they come by themselves and
they resolve everything.
But that, at the end, you see
that, that doesn't happen.
And in the process, the
deterioration of institutions
can bring the country to
a new level of problems.
If we are ready to more
direct forms of democracy,
we are already doing more
direct forms of democracy.
We are participating every day
in politics, wherever we are.
And wherever you're based
and whatever is your country,
you are able to participate
in the political life there
because you have a Twitter,
a Facebook account,
and then you can really create conditions
for public opinion,
and you can bring new issues
to the political system.
And it's a new way of participating,
it's a much more direct one.
And I agree with that,
but that doesn't resolve
everything that democracy needs.
I mean, as I said, we need to face
the problem of inequality.
We need to resolve the
problems of security.
So we need to create conditions
to better produce in the country.
And that, it cannot be done
only chatting in Twitter
or in a social media, there
you have to really work.
And sometimes the people forget
that politics is working, its service.
I mean, you serve people
and you serve people
with a purpose of making
your society better,
but you have to do things.
You have to be a doer, you have to do,
if you only want to talk about politics,
yeah, maybe the social media will end
only replacing our very
serious conversations
that we had in our bars
and cafes in Latin America,
but will not hardly be
enough to solve our problems.
- Mm-hm, yeah, and so,
since you were now talking
about inequality, so that seems to be
a very big structural ancient
problem in Latin America.
There was a point in time
in the 2010s, more or less,
where it seems that some
countries had experienced
a small decrease in inequality.
And people started getting very excited
about seeing a change in
the trend in inequality.
But of course, even before the pandemic,
that reason for hope was already,
we didn't have enough reason to hope
that the trend was going to
continue in that direction.
So I'm just wondering,
you mentioned corruption,
you mentioned inequality,
you mentioned discrimination.
It all points to perhaps
a broken social contract
in many of these countries,
that it's a very complicated problem
because if governments don't
have access to resources,
so if tax revenues are low,
people don't want to pay taxes,
people don't trust that other people
are going to want to pay taxes.
It sort of drops countries
in a negative equilibrium,
in a way, in a very negative cycle,
I'm just wondering how to get out of it?
And I wonder whether
organizations like the OAS
has, sort of a vision of how to promote,
maybe tax agreements, I don't know exactly
what would be the way forward?
And is there room for
international cooperation
to get the country moving
in the right direction?
- International cooperation
is always necessary,
and you always have to
refer to some countries,
some states, some
nations that can be doing
the things in the right way.
So international
cooperation, and you may need
the assistance and the
cooperation of these countries
in order to better do a couple of things
that you want to do in
your country, my country.
Yeah, I was part of a government
that reduced inequality
as much as we could,
and we reduced poverty
to one digit in Uruguay.
And that is, it can be
done, it can be done.
And sometimes people refer to Mujica,
and they prefer a lot more,
his philosophical part.
I highly appreciate more
his professionalism,
he was a professional doing his job,
he worked from very early in the morning.
I was sure that if I would,
I was having a call half
past six in the morning,
it would come from him.
And I was sure that if I
was getting a call at 11
in the evening, it would be from him
and that he would have
20 meetings in a day,
and that he would be trying to deal
with practically every single matter
that exists in the country.
Why we have very few, so you
can do a lot of micromanagement
when even you are, at the same time,
you can be doing high politics
and it can be done, it can be done.
And you have to have the
purpose of that, of course.
You have to have the purpose of bringing
more equal conditions to your people.
If you don't have that
purpose, you won't do it,
but even if you work a lot.
But that is a thing, you
have to bring these solutions
and it's possible to
achieve, and it can be done.
And of course, and that
is what I mean when,
but you have to work the
things in the long term,
it is not enough for, to
work for a couple of years,
to work for 10 years,
to work for 20 years.
I mean, we are in a stage that we need
to work very hard for longer than that.
If our social contract is broken,
I think our social, the
social contract that we have,
and that's why I mention
inequality, discrimination,
paternalistic, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera,
it was a failed social contract.
Maybe it's not broken,
and that is a problem,
maybe they are trying,
they have some people trying
to hold to that old contract
that he has 200 years or 150
years, but we definitely,
we cannot keep going with
that social contract,
we need a more efficient social contract.
We need a social contract that can break
with these structures,
and that can help us
to bring some of the real
solutions that I have mentioned.
So, the problem is that,
maybe is that it's not broken,
but it's a failed one,
it took us for 200 years
without delivering the proper solutions
and it's still there and it's still,
we have to deal with that.
And that is the biggest problem.
So we need a better social contract.
With another problem,
no, I mean, we don't socialize well,
our socialization also
is not an efficient one,
It is not the right one.
You could see it during COVID
times, you could see it.
I mean, and you could see it
in a practically every country.
Sometimes you have very strict measures
of quarantine and all this.
suddenly, but you could
see that at the same time,
they were having, people
having clandestine parties
of 500 people, and we were
people having clandestine party
for less than that, but they
were, and that is the thing,
I mean, we were not, we
don't have this thing that
it may exist here and I think
existed, but I don't know
so much of places in the city,
but, in your way, somehow
existed this community life
that exist here, that
people are responsible
for the neighbor, for what
is going on with the street,
with your sidewalk, with your tree,
with everything is how you
have better community life.
And that is means how you socialize better
in a now, a wider view of
solutions that maybe better,
but the start, a lot of things that start
by you, by you trying to
do things in a better way,
but socializing better.
If you just try to avoid the rules,
avoid the norms, trying
to create conditions
that where you can take some advantages,
but you don't take the
obligations and the duties,
the responsibilities that comes with that
will be very, very difficult.
And that is another problem that we have.
So, we have this problem of
the failed social contract,
but we also have the problem of that,
the wrong way we socialize.
- [Maria] Mm-hm, Secretary General,
I think that we, at this point,
might open the floor for
questions from the audience,
if there is one.
- I have been so clear, I don't
think they have questions.
(crowd laughs)
- Yeah?
- [Student] Hello, so earlier today,
you talked about how
platforms like Facebook--
- Can you please, because...
- [Student] The mask?
- Yeah, please.
- [Student] You always say
you talk about platforms
like Facebook can be used
to express public opinion
and used to kind of promote
like democratic ideals.
Also, we see how platforms like Facebook
can promote like hyper polarization
also can spread misinformation,
which can lead democratic backsliding.
I was wondering whether or not you thought
that kinda like regulating
these social media platforms
should be tackled by
international community,
or something to be handled
domestically by each country?
- You know what, first of all,
if you have common problems,
try to resolve them together.
Because if not, you will
only have a cockroach effect.
I mean, you will stop it somewhere
and it will just move somewhere else.
And so, I think, I was very
tempted to whatever it works,
and of course there are
some levels of the things
that they need to address,
to be addressed at the national level,
because of course, every
country has different scenarios
and they start from different points.
And their social, their
freedom of expression,
or social media or whatever,
is completely different than the country
a couple of thousands of kilometers away.
So there are specificities
that will be needed
to progress at the national level,
but we need to see the common problems
that these generate and
how we can help each other
in order to avoid things that can come
with this digitalization of politics.
And you see permanently these days,
attacks, digital attacks coming
to your country from where
ever else in the world.
And that is something, of course,
that we need to have
a better understanding
of how our digital international
relations should be.
I mean, it cannot be a jungle.
It cannot be like
everybody trying to prevail
with the world tools against others,
but how we can be helpful in order
to create a better
international community.
And of course, any rules that
you bring into the system,
you have to be, designed
them extremely carefully,
because, I mean, any drop that falls,
any drop of ink that falls
into the freedom of expression,
it can be a serious problem,
it will be a serious problem.
So how you can manage
that in order to create
even better conditions
for freedom of expression.
And I am one of the most
insulted people in media.
You know, all my
adversaries, they have trolls
and farms of trolls all around.
I only have my humble
account and I can only say
the most evident truth,
because if one day I lie,
I will be killed.
So, as one of the most
insulted person in media,
I can tell you that it's good
to keep freedom of expression,
and to assure that by all means.
And I don't have any problem
with anonymous insulting me.
I don't have a problem with
that, but I may have a problem
with anonymous committing crimes
like pedophilia or something like that.
So those things, anonymity
cannot be protected
in those cases where you offend the law.
But of course, and I consider
that insulting a politician
is freedom of expression.
So it's where you do that,
and that can be assured.
- [Maria] Mm-hm, yes?
- Good afternoon, My
name is Eka Khorbaladze,
Fox International fellow (mumbles)
First of all, thank you
very much Secretary General
for your time and very interesting talk.
If you let me, I'd have
two parts question.
The first is, you spoke
a lot about democracy
and its importance, and
I wonder, of course,
I agree with that this
is very important value
in which it's possible
to build good government
to develop rules in countries
and in integrational processes.
But, I wonder if we take into account
the example of China and we'll look
how it becomes the great power,
how its economy is growing so accordingly,
the people's condition become better,
living conditions become better,
how we can, and taking
into account what you said
before about democracy, compare it
with what is happening in China.
And the second part of my
question is don't you think
that such kind of building
integration processes
on such value as democracy
reduces the capability
of organization to other countries,
which I would say don't
have democratic regimes?
Thanks a lot.
- Yeah, and I, of course
I will ask you to do so,
I have always said, democracy is the best
in this hemisphere for
development, security
in this hemisphere.
I can not go far beyond my jurisdiction,
as you may realize, in any case,
every country has different
tools and different approaches.
I served as ambassador
of Uruguay to China.
And of course, I saw the
process of a developing country
that, and you could see that every day
they were really economically growing
and economically bringing better
conditions for the people,
and socially bringing better conditions
for the people day by day.
And practically, every Chinese
person was very optimistic
that in the next year, he would be better
than this year and that
has been quite the reason
for an optimist for quite a while.
They have a completely
collective pattern of working.
And I mean, it's for
them collective action.
And this, be a spirit of
doing the things together,
the enhance spirit of
doing the things together
is a completely different one
that we have in this hemisphere,
western hemisphere so far.
So, of course, when we talk about systems,
I don't think you can never
go to an agreement of any kind
where you resign your liberties,
your fundamental freedoms,
your democratic rule of law.
You can't resign that, you
have to keep it with you
because that will be a bigger loss
than anything that can happen.
And, of course, I always
hope that in that process,
more fundamental freedoms
will be available
for Chinese people and
that they may develop
and evolve in that direction.
And that is an imperative that, of course,
we always have to have in mind,
but, what I say is that we
cannot lose what we have
about fundamental freedoms,
because if we do that,
we are going to really
miss them, I can tell you,
we are going to really miss them.
And in this continent, the closer,
the better our democracies work,
the better our conditions
for access to right,
for security and for development,
that is a fact in this continent,
in this continent type.
- Secretary General, we are out of time,
but I want to thank you
so much on behalf of CLAIS
for taking the time, especially now,
considering the
circumstances to talk to us,
thank you so much.
(speaks Spanish)
(laughs)
(crowd claps)
- Thank You
- Thank you so much.